I'm here at the strong National Museum
of play in Rochester New York and they
have set up for the public to enjoy some
of the craziest and rarest arcade games
that I have ever laid my eyes on and I
am going to go play some
so I have to know what is this I've seen
a lot of arcade games but I've never
seen something like this this is a
version of Tetris giant this actually
never made it into foam reduction I
believe this is the only copy in North
America oh really
so if you've seen the Disney animated
movie wreck-it Ralph you might know that
the the movie is based around a game
called fix-it Felix they did such an
amazingly kind of convincing job of of
making it look like you know like a
classic Nintendo game I mean even the
art you know on wreck-it Ralph up here
he's got the little crosses in his teeth
he looks like Donkey Kong on the next
machine over basically so this is
Hercules which I have never ever ever
seen before and it is a massive massive
the world's biggest pinball machine it's
so big it uses a pool cue ball Atari
made a couple hundred of these they
didn't really make very many and there's
there's very very few left in existence
there's very few left in existence that
are in perfect working condition like
the one here at the Museum I have never
gotten to touch one of these but you've
got one of my favorite Super Nintendo
games so I've got to try it on this day
so this is the super system the Nintendo
Super system which was basically it lets
you play Super Nintendo games in the
arcades
this is actraiser it's like one of my
very favorite games of all time on the
Super Nintendo and I'm very surprised to
find that it has an arcade version which
to this day I did not actually know
existed this was a sonic fighting game
this is really cool because even the
biggest song the Hedgehog fans haven't
even played this game I am sitting in an
extremely rare arcade machine right now
this is a RadarScope cabinet it was made
by a Nintendo of America and RadarScope
was actually a very pivotal game in the
history of the gaming industry not
because it was any good but actually
because it was really bad Nintendo of
America ordered a whole bunch of these
but they weren't selling so they had to
replace it with some other game and so
the game they ended up replacing it with
was Donkey Kong which of course you know
not only became a big hit
pollution eyes the whole industry and
Donkey Kong has only ever made because
Nintendo needed a replacement game to
fill all the RadarScope cabinets but not
these I've never ever seen one of these
big full-size sit-down RadarScope
machines before this is absolutely
amazing that arcade game from your
childhood would you most like to play
again just one more time let us know in
the comments and subscribe and then when
you're done with all that go to
Rochester New York check out the
National Museum of play where you might
just get to play it again